hey guys it's justine and today we're
gonna be unboxing something that will
help you clean your house
robots
[Music]
so i have the irobot roomba and the
irobot brava jet my sister actually has
this one and she has been saying how
amazing it is so i'm really excited to
check it out
a huge thank you to irobot for
sponsoring this video i cannot wait
to have a clean house i have purposely
been not cleaning the floors i mean i'm
saying purposely but just like i really
just haven't actually cleaned them so
this is going to be great because
there's a lot of dirt
all over the place but don't worry we're
also going to show you
how it can disappear very quickly let's
unbox
it's been a while since i've been like
super excited to unbox something
i mean i do unbox a lot of stuff but
this is gonna help me keep my life in
order and clean
oh this is its base station
the real question is what are we gonna
name it
seriously really exciting i've been
spending so much more time at home
and to be able to have sort of the
heavily trafficked areas clean
consistently throughout the day
especially the entrance to my little
backyard area because the dog is
constantly in and out of there all day
long so this will be able to
know my high traffic areas and take care
of it for me
i wonder if you make a good dinner
companion
how's your conversational skills mine
are pretty poor
look at this let's get it set up and
then i'll unbox
the bravo jet while this is charging
[Music]
okay brava
jet
oh look at you
this is really sleek looking and we've
got the base station
[Applause]
cables oh look at this
this is a washable wet mopping pad
and here's a couple of the single use
wet mopping pads
here's a sweeping pad so we have a
sweeping pad a mopping pad
and a washable now we need to find a
home for this and then we're gonna set
up the app and get these all synced up
so we can start some cleaning
so i've read all my directions i have
the app downloaded
these guys are all plugged in and now
it's time to set them up let's set up
the
vacuum let's name it roomba
mama press and hold spot and home
spot at home okay i've pressed the
buttons
oh setup is complete welcome to the
world rumble mama this is the best thing
i've ever seen in my life
maddie please we're doing a software
update get hyped
so the update for the roomba mama is
ready so this is just about ready to
clean i'm gonna set up the mop
then start this clean while this charges
it's all a process
but this is gonna be great because once
these are all set up everything will
basically be
automated and i won't have to really do
anything what should we name
this one how about baby brava there we
go
connect to my wi-fi once baby bravo is
connected to your wi-fi i love these
names
this is the best part about it that's
interesting so depending upon which pad
you install into the bravo jet it'll
automatically put it in that mode
there's different automations that you
can set your robots up to do so
you can actually have it set up so that
when you leave the house
the robots will know that you're no
longer here and they'll start cleaning
so that you can return home to a clean
house i also love that this has
integration with alexa
and google i'm like i always bring my
voice down like so they can't hear me
she heard me
she already heard me so with that
integration you'll be able to
communicate with your voice through
those devices to have them clean
a specific room or just clean the house
so we're about to do our first clean and
this has no map data of my house so we
need to do this first clean so that it's
able to kind of get its bearings so
first things first
roomba mama let's get this party started
[Music]
[Applause]
this is you this is your first time
it's learning it's learning
[Music]
i love that he's like not even afraid of
it he's like all right
i have a busy schedule and i also have a
dog who frequently tracks in dirt and
makes a lot of messes i can easily set a
schedule so they can clean specific
rooms on certain days or just clean
every room with imprint link technology
roomba and bravojet are able to mop my
home and clean without me having to do
anything it's really cool because it's
able to
imprint smart mapping to be able to
learn its way around my home
i do have two floors in my house so this
could also learn my upstairs as well as
the downstairs you can choose a room to
be cleaned in the app and you can also
use smart home integration with amazon
alexa and google roomba
clean my kitchen i love that you can
make keep out zones these are virtual
boundaries so i can make sure that my
dog's food and water dishes are off
limits
you can also add clean zones for a place
that might frequently need cleaning like
the kitchen island
or the front door there's an all new
updated app that lets you build out your
own map and customize it with room
dividers
labels and zones you can also add
favorites so with one tap you'll be able
to clean
your preferred room or highly trafficked
areas it's also always learning your
space and it keeps evolving the more you
use it
[Music]
i'm so entertained i've been watching
this thing the whole time
it's navigating around everything like
it found its way out of so many
obstacles
it went under the couch and then came
back out and made its way around the
garbage can i went upstairs to play
video games and then i got a
notification that said roomba mama was
completed so i clean this entire
downstairs return to the base by itself
to do a charge and it also empties
itself so when it returns it'll actually
empty itself
from here into this bag originally i was
going to do a dusting first with a brava
jet but
the roomba did such a great job of
cleaning that we're going to go straight
to the mopping you also have an option
to add some of this bravo jet solution
this is some cleaning solution that you
can put into the reservoir
along with some water which is in here
oh
tank guide look at this instructions
everywhere lift the handles remove the
tank
and we fill this up
so here's the mopping pad this is one of
the one use wet ones and
this little cardboard here that you
install right into the bottom this will
determine
what mode that it places itself into
automatically
then we'll put in our water tank
ready to wet mop it automatically
identified which pad that i put on
and now we're gonna mop everywhere
time for cleaning time for cleaning
i brought in my sister i mentioned her
before because she actually has one of
the irobots as well so i wanted to show
her the new updated app because you
don't actually have it yet the one that
i'm using right now it's in beta and i'm
testing it so when i showed it to her
she's like wait i don't have any of
these features well i thought it was
just like an example and i'm like wait
that's the layout
that's so cool yeah i don't have that
that's really neat so yesterday i filmed
the unboxing of the setup and then
i realized when i was going to finish
this video that i still needed to make
sure that the robot
was doing some more training and it had
some more time to learn my layout
so i did that and i basically lifted up
everything i
i feel like a quick little video but i
put everything up so that it could
completely
really learn the whole area so i put
like my trash can up
i put like everything away so that it
would know the full layout
and then once i put those things back
down it'll know that they're there but i
wanted it to be able to get a sense of
the entire layout so let me show you
this
here it is these are my two rooms so
this is kind of like the kitchen area
and
my living room it's very yeah i know we
can go in and customize
oh that's so cool okay so this is
downstairs
and then we're gonna hit next and so
this is saving everything
that's cool yeah i don't look at this i
don't have that i just i turn it on and
i can like set a schedule but this is
cool look it's letting me set up room
since it already divided it says room
obama tries hard but doesn't always get
rooms exactly right
please review and tweak as needed oh
honestly it did a pretty good job to be
honest with you
this is good look we can add a divider
if we wanted to oh my gosh and i can
just turn it like that
did you guys see that look at this i'm
turning it this is
fascinating i know now we can label each
room oh
i can't wait until yours updates to this
it's gonna be cool tap a room to label
okay okay let's
call this let's just call this kitchen
kitchen kitchen's nice very generic just
this is the kitchen here we go living
room
there you go you can set up favorites so
i can just vacuum everywhere or i can
add my own favorite
so i can set up the kitchen what color
should kitchen be
really a purple okay then you can set up
to mop after i know
i know i know i'm shocked
and then we're gonna click them off
after nice now because you already
cleaned it look at this
choose the mop oh my gosh so i can also
set a schedule which is kind of cool
because if i wanted this to clean up
basically like after my day of
you know existing and making messes in
my house yeah i can set it to start how
about like nine o'clock yes
that sounds good and then we can also do
an automation so if i want to enable
this
it'll know that whenever i leave it can
just start cleaning so that when i come
back it'll be nice and clean
that is pretty cool you can also set up
zones so maddie's food and his dish
is usually like over there look at this
i can zoom in
whoa and we can add a keep out zone
that's really cool i know it's probably
about that much maybe
okay so we're gonna save it because i
don't want his little food dude no
it'll bump it yeah or the one time he
was eating dinner and the
vacuum was coming and he's just like so
unbothered by it i'm like buddy
move move maddie get out the way i'm
eating leave me alone
so thanks for joining my video yeah i
was excited when you told me i was like
you've done a lot of cool things but i
was really
excited about this and when i told her
there was a brava jet that mops
lost my mind thank you guys so much for
watching i put a link in the description
if you guys want to check out
both of these the irobot roomba and the
irobot brava jet
i'm obsessed now you're gonna have to
get yourself a grab a jet i know it's so
cute
i love it i'm just kidding should i just
have them clean again yes i think so
okay
why not all right okay
[Music]
you